and there are rising concerns about the
mass arrests
across the line of control in the indian
administered side
[Music]
political leaders activists and
academics have been rounded up over the
past few weeks and months
and are now being held in indian jails
yasi malek is one a popular separatist
kashmiri leader
seen here at one of his court
appearances in india his wife now says
he's critically ill
this clamp down is unbelievable and when
my sister-in-law they meet him
it's just like he's locked up in a glass
room and uh
and he and they were telling me that he
can't even get up i mean
uh he he is so weak and doctors from the
heart have also said that he must be
shifted
to an icu i mean and his or previous
doctors his cardiologists his kidney
specialist was said that he's going to
die like this
michelle made a birthday video for him
centered around the couple's young child
in 10 years of marriage she spent only
60 days with him because of his
continual arrests
the indians call him a terrorist
although he has friends in high places
in pakistan
his partner insists he's a freedom
fighter who's renounced violence
and is an example of what's happening to
all kashmiris now
he's given his youth his blood
everything and his only hope
is that the world will come forward so
if this is
time is running short so i appeal to the
world to especially the permanent five
countries
uh and the united nations security
council that you know
wake up this is not a time of statements
we have to stop this
and if you see the situation at the loc
the cluster bombs
it's it's non-stop and it's it's
aggravating day
by day day by day the pakistan
authorities produce
these pictures as evidence they found
cluster bombs which they blame on
india for firing they want kashmir
discussed by the un security council
as a matter of urgency
the crisis coincides with the appearance
of the indian prime minister on a
survival tv program fronted by british
adventurer bear grylls
my job is to keep you alive it's already
caused controversy because of the timing
with some indian opposition politicians
suggesting prime minister modi was
filming it
at the time of the mass killing of
indian soldiers
patriotic fervor is sweeping both
countries ahead of separate independence
day celebrations this week
kashmir will overshadow it all alex
crawford sky news islamabad